[Applaudissements]
je m'appelle je rappelle les chéris
qu'il est 19h13 et on est en direct sur
C8 bien entendu C8 premières chaînes TNT
et de loin merci à vous et d'être aussi
nombreux et je voudrais dire pour TPMP
record historique vraiment semaine
historique on a fait que des jours à
plus de 2 millions lundi mardi mercredi
jeudi une moyenne
2 millions 200000
merci les chéris
je vous jure on se rend pas compte mais
c'est monstrueux
spectateurs de moyenne de moyenne c'est
franchement jamais on aurait cru pouvoir
faire ça donc merci à vous voilà et bien
sûr premier talk sur l'ensemble de tout
voilà de tout pourriez-vous voilà
surtout premier toc de France toutes
chaînes confondues merci à vous d'être
aussi nombreux voilà merci et c'est un
bonheur et dire qu'on arrive à faire des
succès avec ça c'est quand même
exactement comment il va sûrement ça va
aller on n'est pas là pour discuter
je suis quand même payé et bien
justement cette émission cartonne vous
l'avez vu plus de 2 millions de
téléspectateurs et si vous à la maison
et bien vous cherchez un stage de 3e ou
que votre enfant c'est bien cherche un
stage de 3e n'hésitez pas à venir chez
Baba pour tout ce qui est culture
générale tout ce qui est apprentissage
tout ce qui est manque des médias
l'exemple avec Clément qui était notre
stage de 3e cette semaine
un apprentissage au quotidien
troisième
un truc de rêve c'est vrai que c'est
cool de rencontrer Guillaume Genton qui
est comme un peu un grand frère dans le
métier
le stagiaire fait totalement partie de
l'équipe regardez à quel point cyril est
à l'aise avec lui
ok
[Musique]
l'apprentissage du patron à son
stagiaire
[Rires]
et c'est pas fini même pendant les
débats hyper sérieux Baba n'hésite pas à
se confier à son petit stagiaire
c'est pour le distrait voilà ça va je
l'embrasse en tout cas il faut qu'il
revienne une belle transmission
pour le rapport de stage
c'était une grande semaine Cyril pour
Guillaume j'attends qui a retrouvé son
acolyte de plateau sur la colline de
toujours Jean messiya alors sans papiers
ils ont rien à voir ensemble sauf que
quand on les met tous les deux à côté
sur plateau standard
tous les jours
à la télé
ma couille carrément vous souvenez de
cette séquence avec Enock Cortes
était venu le conseiller en comme de
jean-metière tu dis frérot concentre-toi
la Mecque des stats elles vont faire
comme ça
je te dis là
tu vas être partout sur Tik Tok du
coaching et surtout une vraie complicité
entre les deux ça va c'est ma couille
tu vois rien tu vois
tu commences à rentrer dans le game
c'est pas normal
je veux poser une question Benjamin
Castaldi parce que vous étiez pas là
lors de ma dernière chronique et bien
figurez-vous que Cyril et Matthieu
Delormeau vous ont mis plein la tronche
oui mais comme à chaque fois non
les pubs pendant les pubs donc j'étais
venu montrer ces images là mais
rassurez-vous cette semaine ils se sont
rattrapés ils ont dit que du bien de
vous non pas du tout
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
donc des compliments on passe au tuto
modestie de la semaine et évidemment il
est signé Mathieu Delormeau vous en
doutez
le jambon non mais c'est vrai tu as
raison c'est pour ça que les gens
commencent à le
recruter en vrai en vrai tu enlèves toi
moi et un peu comment il s'appelle
Olivier Minne il y a pas un animateur
qui est beau
[Applaudissements]
je le pense vraiment je le trouve très
bon en ce moment ne dit pas n'importe
quoi
je te jure je te trouve très beau tu es
bien plus beau que Mathieu Delormeau
d'ailleurs qui lui par contre après un
coup
c'est vrai
[Musique]
alors il est très beau mais regarde son
teint comme il est beau toi frère sur la
tête de ma mère un vampire escarpa pas
dormi depuis 8 ans
mes frères sans déconner frère blanc ah
non c'est pas que tu es blanc frère tu
étais en fait
tu as pas un fan dans le
non non tu vas me réchauffer tout ça
d'accord faut que tu partes en vacances
toi très loin
non non mais je te jure il regarde
castani un très beau temps vraiment je
trouve que tu as une belle peau beaucoup
de sport ouais je sais très beau non non
c'est rabougri
alors je remets une petite couche
j'ai une petite question pour vous Cyril
parce que il en faut un peu pour tout le
monde est-ce que vous aviez des
difficultés à vous concentrer quand vous
étiez en cours
pas du tout parce que même quelques
années plus tard en étant le patron de
votre propre émission vous n'arrivez
toujours pas à vous concentrer le
problème c'est quand il y a des invités
qui viennent parler de sujets Cyril
parfois on le perd totalement je vous
laisse regarder c'est apprendre dans les
cours d'animateur c'était quoi ça il
s'agit bien de la plus grande fraude
alimentaire mise au jour c'est fou ça
non mais sans rigoler non je te le dis
Xavier il y a aussi de la production qui
est où les gens sont payés correctement
bien sûr monsieur les choses sont faites
faut faire quand même bien sûr bien sûr
ce qui est important de de dire les
sucres par exemple ce sont les produits
du kracking c'est dire des tracking ils
utilisent beaucoup ça aux États-Unis
priori ça peut paraître coûter cher
utopique
et je parlais de Christophe de manger
tout de suite ou deux on l'embrasse
Christophe il démontrer qu'on pouvait
faire à manger j'ai ramené des produits
de saison quoi ça ça c'est une teub
alors donc ça ça vaut en ce moment entre
en fonction des régions où tu es entre 1
euro et 2 euros ça se mange ça ça se
mange
[Applaudissements]
c'est pas grave c'est pas grave Anthony
ça te plaît
il adore ça il habite à côté de Rennes
bah oui bah faut un peu faut accueillir
Daniel le plus souvent
[Rires]
ça va ma chérie ça va ça va ce weekend
elle va au théâtre monsieur acheter une
place au premier rang on va voir André
Dussollier
il va jouer sa pièce tu crois qu'il va
te remarquer on verra c'est quoi la
pièce c'est ça s'appelle
photos
[Rires]
cette voix j'adore cette voix
il se souvient toujours de notre
première rencontre quand j'étais toute
jeune enfin voilà
je l'attendais avec mon petit carnet
d'autographes et maintenant il me voit
dans le métier donc il est content
[Rires]
j'aurais aimé
on me l'a proposé moi m'a proposé cette
pièce
[Applaudissements]
on dirait qu'il Vergès
[Rires]
il commence à stresser parce que c'est
qu'il va devoir faire le canard pendant
48 heures et je peux te dire que c'est
dur mais c'est vrai que c'est quoi que
tu as prévu quoi comme faire on ira
faire le marché ensemble peut-être qu'il
est avec qui à tout
le marché avec elle mais elle a pas
envie de faire le marché avec toi je
sais mais je l'oblige à venir
tout seul
[Rires]
et donc et après le marché en cuisine
parce que je rate jamais c'est la
vaisselle
machine ça c'est ton plaisir parce que
c'est très sexuel de laver les objets
avec l'eau pendant que ta meuf elle est
en train de dormir dans la chambre
j'arrive pas à me concentrer je vais
cassé de nos assiettes avec tes
conneries non mais sérieux et donc après
après la vaisselle bah repos après la
vaisselle je suis fatigué donc c'est
tout
marche en bord de rivière ah ouais ça
c'était la dernière la rivière de votre
enfance entre marnes entre Marne et
scène itinéraire on fait de la marche
tous les deux
cet enfant il va s'arrêter
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
[Musique]
ça veut dire pas de ton portable tu fais
48 43 c'est que c'est pas bon ça
répondra pas hein 07 maintenant
j'ai l'impression que dès qu'on parle de
Daniel toi tu es
ce qu'on appelle en embuscade
il est tapé dans l'ombre après
intervenir sur Daniel non non je connais
Anthony vas-y bébé puisqu'on parle
d'amour de Saint-Valentin tout ça tout
ça figurez-vous qu'il y en a un qui a
passé une Saint-Valentin catastrophique
non c'est pas ça
Valentin hier
la fête des canards
faites des canards WC
qui a fait la Saint-Valentin quelle peut
aller bolosse
les téléspectateurs qu'ils ont regardé
du 98 en direct tu vois chérie on est
bien mieux l'outil que c'était et les
chroniqueurs est-ce que tu as vu leur
vie de merde sans déconner entre l'autre
c'est un mini hachoir Seb il fait tout
dans la maison
c'est un robot multicuiseur
[Applaudissements]
avec moi
on va s'en faire je te jure c'est vrai
chroniqueurs
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je mange pas de sopalin
t'inquiète pas on va s'appeler mais moi
mais j'oublie pas également Ilona
les pommes tombent rarement loin de
l'arbre
c'est quand on vient à Bordeaux
vous savez c'est la manifestante qui a
montré sa poitrine en direct alors
évidemment une dame qui montre ses
pièges à l'antenne ça peut interpeller
mais il y en a un qui était un peu plus
qu'interpellé on peut dire qu'il était
décontenancé c'est qui c'est bouder
regardez bien sa tête
moi ça me choque autant les deux voilà
j'ai le droit de le dire
et voyez voilà
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bisous bisous
gros bisous mon Dieu tout
[Musique]
c'est pour moi
merci merci à la semaine prochaine merci
[Applaudissements]